nadège comment se déroule de votre côté
cette contre manifestation
[Musique]
oui vous l'avez dit un contre
manifestation organisée toujours dans le
14e arrondissement de paris mais cette
fois du côté de montparnasse
manifestation à l'appel d'une dizaine
d'organisations d'ultra gauche 1-2
d'organisations anti fasciste dont le
nouveau parti anticapitaliste et cette
manifestation ici a été interdite par la
préfecture de police de paris parce que
dit elle déclaré trop tard par les
organisateurs alors ils sont ici
quelques dizaines seulement de
manifestants à avoir fait le déplacement
sur cette place du 18 juin 1940 un pour
protester contre la manifestation
organisée du côté de denfert rochereau 1
contre donc la dissolution de génération
identitaire un voulue par gérald
darmanin le ministre de l'intérieur
alors elle est sous haute tension cette
manifestation ici puisque je les dis
elle est interdite et vous le voyez
derrière moi les manifestants présents
ici et bien ont été menacés par les
forces de l'ordre les contrôles de
police ce sont des très importants et
plusieurs manifestants d'ailleurs été
interpellé ici dont jérôme rodriguez le
gilet jaune
c'était il ya un quart d'heure à peu
près il a violemment été interpellé par
des membres des forces de l'ordre ici
alors qu'il avait fait le déplacement
pour manifester pacifiquement participer
à cette contre-manifestation
du coup contre génération identitaire
donc voilà le 14e arrondissement il est
sous haute tension et de manière plus
importante ici sur cette place du 18
juin 1940 puisque les autorités
craignent que les deux manifestations se
rejoignent en fin de journée et que du
coup la situation ne dégénère voilà
pourquoi il vient le dispositif de
sécurité est extrêmement important ici
que les manifestants on peut le dire sur
cette contre-manifestation et bien sont
empêchées de manifester et du kun assez
comme vous pouvez le voir derrière moi
merci nadège abderrazak en direct donc
du quartier de montparnasse à paris